2G auch für Kinder und Jugendliche also
auch Kinder und Jugendliche werden
ausgesperrt sozusagen wenn sie nicht
geimpft sind alle über 12 können sich
impfen lassen aber sie dürfen eben in
Bayern nicht mehr alles das war die
Berichterstattung auch von Bild schon
gestern jetzt gibt es ein winzigen ein
mini-rückzieher von Markus Söder den man
noch mal kurz erklären müssen Paul ja
der Mini Rückzieher betrifft Engagement
im Sportverein zum Beispiel also Kinder
und Jugendliche dürfen dort hin ohne
Test in dem Moment und da gilt dann eine
Ausnahme aus tatsächlich nur eine
mini-ausnahme ansonsten will Markus
Söder das so durchziehen und man hat ihm
angemerkt dass er sich da auch weiterhin
sehr auf der richtigen Seite wehnt und
all diejenigen die aus seiner Sicht das
war ein winkrichtung Ampel das ganze
verharmlosen dass die Dramatik nicht
sehen liegen aus Sicht von Markus Söder
falsch ohne Impfung ne dürfen sie zum
Sport du sagte
in einer Schule regelmäßig getestet dass
also die Tür die ja auffällt dass er
sagt die Kinder auch ab 12 bekommen
natürlich regelmäßige Testungen dürfen
natürlich in den Schulen ohnehin hier in
Berlin beispielsweise drei Mal in der
Grundschule zu müssen
gesellschaftlichen Konflikt auch
aufgemacht hat in dieser Pressekonferenz
dass er auch ganz offen diese starke
Polarisierung diese Trennung im Moment
in der Gesellschaft zwischen geimpften
und ungeimpften auch kritisch
angesprochen hat aber befeuert er das
nicht gerade mit dieser Ausweitung noch
mal der 2g-regelung Markus Söder
befeuert diese Spaltung wie kein anderer
Politiker auf der einen Seite er hat
sich immer als knallhart als der
härteste präsentiert und man muss sagen
er hat allerdings momentan die
schlechtesten Werte also die Strategie
die Markus Söder verfolgt nämlich zu
sagen wir greifen durch die sieht man
zumindest nicht bei den Zahlen auf der
Intensivstation bzw bei den Fällen und
die sieht man auch nicht bei der Impfung
auf bei allen Experten ist Bayern im
Vergleich schlecht also muss man sagen
da ist auch viel große Klappe am Ende
und jetzt sind es wieder die Kinder die
Kinder und Jugendlichen die so oft Paul
in dieser Krise eh schon die
Leidtragenden waren und wir hatten ja
auch hier in dieser Sendung mit einer
Mutter geredet die sagt ja was soll ich
jetzt machen also selbst wenn ich jetzt
sofort mit meiner Teenager-Tochter dabei
ein Teenager Sohn zum Impfen renne dann
dauert ja trotzdem noch um die fünf
Wochen bis der oder diese wirklich an
dem sozialen Leben teilnehmen ins Kino
gehen darf oder in die Disco gehen darf
also da setzen wir ja trotzdem fünf
Wochen aus was ist das für ein Signal
was man da setzt und wie groß ist auch
die Befürchtung bei dir das andere
Bundesländer danach ziehen könnten ich
glaube es ist ein verheerendes Signal
Richtung Kinder und Jugendliche die ja
wirklich die schwächsten waren in dieser
Pandemie in den vergangenen anderthalb
Jahren die oft ihre Freunde nicht sehen
konnten die Schulen waren dicht also
genau diese Problematik was dann im
sozialen Umfeld passiert ja also was
sozusagen die Folgeschäden auf der
anderen Seite sind darüber redet Markus
Söder nicht stattdessen redet er darüber
dass er die Hoffnung hat dass auch bald
noch jüngere Kinder geimpft werden
können und verweist auf Österreich und
sagt dass dort das eben möglich sein er
verstünde gar nicht warum in Deutschland
das nicht möglich sei also ich glaube er
macht da einen eine neue Spaltung und
die er unbedingt verhindern will auf
seiner Seite wieder auf ja also er
emotionalisiert diese Debatte seit
Wochen seit Monaten seit Jahren immer
entscheidend mit und jetzt wundert er
sich dass es da eine gesellschaftliche
Debatte gibt